D
CHALIAN.
THANKS TO JEFF ZELENY.
LET'S GO TO DAVID CHALIAN WHO
HAS OUR FIRST EXIT POLLS.
DAVID, WHAT'S ON THE MINDS OF
THE VOTERS?
>> YEAH JAKE, FIRST I WANT TO
SAY THESE ARE PRELIMINARY,
INITIAL EXIT POLL RESULTS.
THESE ARE SURVEYS THAT WE'VE
DONE.
VOTERS --
VOTERS ON ELECTION DAY AS WELL
AS TENS OF MILLIONS OF VOTERS
WHO VOTED PRIOR TO ELECTION
DAY.
THIS IS A REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE
OF THE OVERALL ELECTORATE.
SO, WE WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT THE NATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
LOOKS LIKE FOR VOTERS VOTING IN
THIS MIDTERM ELECTION.
FEELINGS ABOUT THE WAY THINGS
ARE GOING IN THE U.S..
THIS IS A BLEAK PICTURE FROM
THIS ELECTORATE.
LOOK DOWN HERE.
39% DISSATISFIED, 34% ARE
DOWNRIGHT ANGRY.
THAT'S 73%.
THREE QUARTERS OF THE
ELECTORATE TELL US THEY ARE
DISSATISFIED OR ANGRY.
ONLY 5% ENTHUSIASTIC, 20%
SATISFIED.
JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING, A
KEY MARKER IN MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
45% OF THOSE VOTING IN THIS
MIDTERM ELECTION, NATIONALLY,
45% APPROVE OF THE JOB AND
SUING.
54% DISAPPROVE.
THIS KIND OF LOOKS LIKE WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN A LOT OF THE PRE
ELECTION POLLING.
HE'S UPSIDE DOWN AND HE'S WELL
BELOW 50% APPROVAL.
WHAT ABOUT BIDEN AS A FACTOR IN
YOUR VOTE?
WELL, HE'S A FACTOR FOR ABOUT
HALF OF THOSE VOTING TODAY.
18%, THOUGH, SAY THE FACTOR IS
THEY ARE SUPPORTING BIDEN WITH
THEIR VOTE TODAY.
32%, A THIRD OF PEOPLE VOTING
IN THIS ELECTION, SAY, THEY'RE
DOING SO TO OPPOSE JOE BIDEN.
48%, THE OTHER HALF, ROUGHLY,
SAY BIDEN IS NOT A FACTOR AT
ALL.
HOW ABOUT BIDEN POLICIES?
ARE THEY HELPING OR HURTING THE
COUNTRY?
WELL, ACCORDING TO THESE EARLY,
PRELIMINARY EXIT POLLS, AGAIN,
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS MAY SHIFT
AS WE GET MORE SURVEY DATA IN,
46% OF THE ELECTORATE SAYS
BIDEN'S POLICIES ARE HURTING
THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S COMPARED 36%, A SMALLER
PORTION, WHO SAY HIS POLICIES
ARE HELPING.
16% SAY THEY'RE NOT MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AT ALL.
>> DAVID CHALIAN, THOSE ARE
BRUTAL NUMBERS FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN RIGHT.
THERE I HAVE TO SAY, THE LAST
ONE IS, TO ME, THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT.
THE PLURALITY, 46% SAY BIDEN'S
POLICIES ARE HURTING THE
COUNTRY.
16%, NOT MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
IT'S NOT EXACTLY ARIZONIAN
DORTMUND EITHER.
THAT'S 63% OF THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT THINK HIS POLICIES
ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY OR
THEY'RE NOT MAKING ANY
DIFFERENCE.
>> AND A THIRD SAYING THAT
THEY'RE USING THEIR VOTE, EVEN
THOUGH JOE BIDEN'S NOT ON THE
BALLOT, TO SHOW THEIR
OPPOSITION TO HIM WITH REGARD
TO CONGRESS OR OTHERS.
TO ME, THOUGH, THE WHOLE BALL
GAME IS THAT FIRST ONE, YOU
KNOW?
WE COVERED POLITICS FOR A LONG
TIME AND YES, THERE ARE THINGS
THAT CHANGE A LOT.
ONE THING THAT HAS NEVER
CHANGED IS WHAT WE CALL RIGHT
TRACK, RUN TRACK.
WHETHER PEOPLE FEEL JUST FEEL
GOOD OR NOT ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
THE FACT THAT ALMOST 75%, SO
THREE QUARTERS OF AMERICANS,
ARE EITHER DISSATISFIED OR
DOWNRIGHT ANGRY, THAT IS
BRUTAL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS LINING UP?
THREE FIRST TERM IN TERM
ELECTIONS, THE FIRST MIDTERM
AFTER A NEW PRESIDENT, 94,
CLINTON.
2010, OBAMA, 2018, TRUMP, AND
IN ALL OF THOSE CASES, THE
PRESIDENTS PARTY --
THE DEMOCRATS WON THE
REPUBLICAN LAST BETWEEN 40 AND
62 SEATS.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE UNHAPPY WITH
THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY, AND
THEY DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS HELPING, THEY THINK HE'S
HURTING, THEY TAKE IT OUT ON
THE PRESIDENTS PARTY.
AND I DON'T KNOW WE WILL SEE 40
TO 63 SEATS FULL HOUSE, BUT IT
DOESN'T BODE WELL FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> SOMETIMES IT'S REALLY THAT
SIMPLE.
I THINK THE CANDIDATES AND
CAMPAIGNS OFTEN WANT TO MAKE IT
ABOUT ALL KINDS OF OTHER STUFF.
BUT WHEN AMERICANS ARE UNHAPPY
AND, IN THIS CASE, WE KNOW
THEY'RE UNHAPPY ABOUT THE STATE
OF THE ECONOMY AND THEIR
POCKETBOOKS, IT REALLY KIND OF
BOILS DOWN TO THAT.
THE PARTY IN POWER GETS
PENALIZED FOR THE SOUR MOVE
THAT THIS ELECTORATE.
>> THE REALITY HERE, THIS
NUMBER, 25% OF PEOPLE ARE
ENTHUSIASTIC OR SATISFIED.
THAT MEANS THAT THERE ARE A
HECK OF A LOT OF DEMOCRATS OUT
THERE WHO ARE DISSATISFIED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S GO TO DAVID CHALIAN, HE
HAS MORE NUMBERS FROM THE EXIT
POLLS.
DAVID?
JAKE, WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
THE ISSUES THAT ARE DRIVING
VOTERS DECISIONS IN THIS
ELECTION.
WE ASKED FOLKS IN THE EXIT POLL,
AND AGAIN, THIS IS PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION.
WE WILL GET MORE AS THE NIGHT
GOES ON.
WHAT WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO YOUR VOTE?
INFLATION, FOR 32% OF THE
ELECTORATE.
THIS IS A NATIONAL LOOK AT
THOSE SHOWING UP TO VOTE TODAY.
INTERESTINGLY, ABORTION, 27% OF
THE ELECTORATE SAID IT WAS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THEIR
VOTE.
THAT'S SORT OF A CLOSER SECOND
THAN WE'VE SEEN IN A LOT OF
PREELECTION PULLING.
CRIME AT 12%, GUN POLICY, THE
SAME PLACE, 12%.
AND IMMIGRATION, DOWN TO 10%.
LISTENING INTO THAT ISSUE,
NUMBER ONE, INFLATION.
WHEN YOU ASK FOLKS, WHAT IS THE
CONDITION OF THE NATION'S
ECONOMY?
WHAT YOU SEE HERE IS THREE
QUARTERS OF THE ELECTORATE, 36%,
SAY NOT SO GOOD.
39%, AT THAT TOGETHER, 75% OF
THE ELECTORATE TODAY SAYS,
THUMBS DOWN ON THE STATE OF THE
NATION'S ECONOMY.
WE ALSO ASKED, HAS INFLATION
CAUSE HARM TO YOUR FAMILY?
HARDSHIP TO YOUR FAMILY?
20% OF VOTERS TODAY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TELL US, SEVERE
HARDSHIP.
ANOTHER 58% TELL US, MODERATE
THAT'S CAMPAIGN TOGETHER NEARLY
EIGHT IN TEN VOTERS AT ARE
EXPERIENCING SOME KIND OF
HARDSHIP.
22% SAY, NO HARDSHIP.
AND WE ASKED, HOW DOES YOUR
FINANCIAL SITUATION COMPARED TO
WHAT IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO?
SORT OF THE CLASSIC POLITICAL
QUESTION.
46% OF VOTERS IN THIS ELECTION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE TELLING
US, THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION
IS WORSE THAN TWO YEARS AGO.
35% SAY, ABOUT THE SAME.
ONLY 18% SAY, BETTER.
AND GAS PRICES, SPECIFICALLY,
AS YOU GUYS KNOW, THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
GAS PRICES EVERY DAY.
YES, 61% OF VOTERS IN THIS
ELECTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TELL US, GAS PRICES HAVE BEEN A
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR THEM.
38% SAY, NO, JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, DAVID CHALIAN,
THANKS SO MUCH.
AND DANA BASH, I MEAN, AGAIN,
75% OF THE COUNTRY SAYS THE
CONDITION OF THE NATION'S
ECONOMY IS NOT SO GOOD OR POOR.
70% OF THOSE IN THE EXIT POLLS
SAY, THE INFLATION IS CAUSED A
FAMILY SEVERE OR MODERATE
HARDSHIP.
AGAIN, BRUTAL NUMBERS.
>> BRUTAL NUMBERS, BUT THE
FIRST POLL THAT THEY'VE SHOWED
US OF WHICH OBVIOUSLY DOES HAVE
INFLATION AT THE TOP.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IT'S NOT A
SURPRISE.
THE SECOND ONE BEING ABORTION,
27% OF PEOPLE SAYING THAT THAT
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
THEIR VOTE, TALKED TO DEMOCRATS
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY SAY, THAT'S THE REASON WHY
A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
ARE EVEN IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW.
NOT THAT IT'S REALLY GOING TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME ULTIMATELY
OF CONTROL, BUT IT AT LEAST
KEEPS DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES --
>> WHAT'S SO INTERESTING IS
THAT, AND I'M NOT SAYING I AM
SURPRISED THAT ABORTION TURNS
OUT TO BE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE.
BUT DEMOCRATS, LAST TIME I
CHECKED, HAD SPENT TEN TIMES
MORE ON ADVERTISING ON ABORTION
THEN THEY HAD ON INFLATION.
AND I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
LOOK BACK AT THAT, I MEAN,
CLEARLY IT WAS A DOBBS MIRAGE.
THEY THOUGHT THAT THE DOBBS
DECISION OVERTURNING ROE V.
WADE WAS GOING TO BE A SILVER
BULLET, GOING TO CARRY THEM TO
VICTORY.
>> WE --
I WOULD DESCRIBES THE DOBSON
AREA AS A MIRAGE.
I THINK WHEN YOU TALKED TO
REPUBLICANS AND OF THE SUMMER
AND DEMOCRATS, IT WAS VERY,
VERY REAL.
IT TOTALLY CHANGED THE DYNAMIC.
DEMOCRATS WOULD SAY THEY HAD TO
MAX, THEY HAD TO HIT THE GAS ON
ABORTION, MAXIMIZE THAT BECAUSE
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
EXITS.
A FULL QUARTER OF THE
ELECTORATE CAME OUT TO VOTE ON
THAT ISSUE, BUT THE PROBLEM IS
ONE THING THAT STICKS AROUND
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THIS IS THE
ECONOMY, AND THAT'S WHAT IS
REARING BACK TO THE FOREFRONT
FOR SO MANY.
>> I THOUGHT WAS WAS PRETTY
INTERESTING HERE, WHICH DAVID
CHALIAN POINTED OUT, IS THAT
THE NUMBERS IN THESE EXITS DO
NOT LINE UP WITH WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IN THE POLLING DATA
GOING INTO THIS ELECTION ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE CARED ABOUT AND THE
ORDER IN WHICH THEY RANKED IT.
SO, WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THROUGHOUT THIS TIME
ABOUT NEW VOTERS, PEOPLE THAT
HAD NOT BEEN IN THERE BEFORE
THEY WERE PERHAPS NOT GETTING
CAPTURED BY THE POLLING, SO
MAYBE THIS IS A SIGN THAT WE
ARE GOING TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THAT --
AND CAN BE EXPECTED.
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T KNOW YET.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S MISSING FROM
THIS ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR,
FIVE, TOP FIVE ISSUES?
DEMOCRACY.
>> OH YEAH.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN IN HERE.
NOT TO SAY THAT IS NOT AN ISSUE
FOR PEOPLE, BUT IT'S NOT EVEN
COMING CLOSE.
>> I DO THINK THAT WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THE EXIT, WHERE
PEOPLE SAID, I'M UNHAPPY ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY'S
GOING, I'M ANGRY, I WANT TO HOW
MANY OF THAT IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
ANGRY ABOUT THE STATE OF OUR
POLITICS.
>> THE STATE OF OUR POLITICS,
YEAH.
NO, ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S TOUGH TO READ THESE POLL
NUMBERS WITHOUT MORE DETAIL.
OBVIOUSLY, ABORTION 27%.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THEY'RE ALL
SUPPORTIVE OF ABORTION.
>> I WILL TELL YOU THOUGH, THE